головне побоювання полягає в тому, що це
підготовка нового військового наступу,
можливо, для створення сухопутного
коридору між донським автобусом,
нині окупованими територіями
донського автобуса та Кримом, що було б
найгіршим тлумаченням, оскільки тоді це могло б
означати велику  -масштабна війна з
тисячами, можливо, навіть десятками
тисяч жертв і великими наслідками
за межами України, але, можливо, це також
те, що більше спрямоване на те, щоб просто
посилити у вас відчуття незахищеності
в Україні, щоб відлякати інвесторів і
зробити Захід більш зацікавленим  знайти
якесь рішення з Росією, щоб це
могло мати інші цілі, для мене
навряд чи було б дуже
дурно з російської сторони почати
широкомасштабну війну проти України